welcome back to new rock stars unaired
Voss in Black Widow released a trailer
giving us our first look at marble face
for the bright action-packed future of a
character we just saw died look I love
be grounded espionage driven Captain
America Winter Soldier asked by that the
Black Widow movies given off here so
let's go through this trailer frame by
frame for all the details that you might
have missed that help explain how Black
Widow fits in the Marvel timeline the
deeper conspiracy of this plot and what
the hell hopper from stranger things is
doing here boiler warning in case I get
anything to rights and let's get started
I used to have nothing
okay the trailer opens on Budapest the
setting of some mysterious past mission
hinted at by Clint Barton and Natasha
Romanov a number of times we know this
is Budapest by the shot of the freedom
statue which commemorates the liberation
of Hungary at the end of World War two
by the Soviet Union throughout the Cold
War Hungary was very much within
Russia's sphere of influence toad
Natasha Romanov and her former KGB
operatives would have a lot of business
here this opening clip recycles
Natasha's line to cap an Avengers
endgame you said nothing and then I got
this this is John his family in the
footage we see is recycled from
Natasha's Red Room memories in age of
Ultron tsar goodbye Scarlet Witch it's
nightmare sorcery was also shot of NAT
leading cap and banner on to the bridge
of the shield Helicarrier and the first
Avengers to meet Nick Fury but let's
move on to the second part of this
[Music]
before we continue thank you to raid
Shadow legends for sponsoring this
episode
raid is one of the top three ranked RPGs
on the Google Play Store and it's just
been nominated as a finalist for Google
play's best of 2019 users Choice Award
15 million downloads in the last six
months
raid is an epic dark fantasy done right
a hero collection turn-based game with
over 400 champions for you to collect
and personally customized in the best
part it's free to play raid is adding
more than 16 new champions every month
so there's always new ways to play and
once you complete the missions you will
get one of the best champions of the
game the arbiter you'll also get tons of
free Champions equipment and other cool
stuff just for learning to play you can
raid with friends in the clan gather
some orcs with your buds explore a
million champion builds and 13 locations
with that guy date of your friends
friend you know I'm talking about games
grown super fast and check out this cool
road map they publish a new faction a
taxi marina feature and even a new clan
boss you'll be able to fight with your
clan mates go to the video description
click on the special links and if you
are a new player you will get 100,000
silver plus 1 energy refill plus one day
xp booster 3000 one times one plus one
free champion executioner all this
treasure will be waiting for you here
this clip singles out one or more
moments between Natasha and Clint from
Avengers and Natasha and fury from
winter soldiers might signal the other
MCU characters who could make surprise
cameos in this film
Hawkeye obviously as someone who joined
Natasha on some past Budapest mission
but also Nick Fury who mentioned having
contacts in the city as late as the 90s
and captain Natasha adds some new voice
of her audio to the end game line but
nothing lasts forever
a meta nod to her fate and end game but
also maybe a reference to the job and
family that she had before joining the
Avengers he's apparently Natasha didn't
have nothing before joining cap dark and
the others she had a crew of Russians
but the fact that she considers those
people not family suggests me that these
spies will not really have her back in
this film they claim to be family but I
think they'll betray her in a key ways
to make her feel truly alone before she
meets the Avengers but before we move on
in this trailer the Marvel Studios title
card is coloured red in black morphing
into the red and black Black Widow
though her iconography from her original
comics inspired by trigger warning if
you're in arachnophobe the red
hourglass-shaped mark on the other side
of the abdomen of the black widow spider
on to the next clip I heard you had to
leave in a hurry
it's never easy these days
so what are you going to do I've lived a
lot of lives but I'm done running from
my past okay here we hear the voice of
Thunderbolt Ross talking about Natasha
having to leave in a hurry as we see her
D boarding a train this movie is set in
at least two time periods one in the gap
of time between the events of Civil War
and infinity war after Natasha turn on
Team Iron Man which was backed by
secretary Ross to join Captain America's
fugitive team on the run but the film
will also flash back to an earlier
period currently undefined evidenced by
this shot of Ross apparently with the
de-aging technology that Marvel has used
in the past with Nick Fury Tony Stark
Hank Pym and Janet Van Dyne
and of course egos human form it looks
like they used William Hertz blonde -
Ian's appearance from his days making
films like broadcast news this presents
some questions about the overall
timeline because this must take place
significantly earlier than even the
mid-2000s because Ross seemed older as
the general in the Incredible Hulk then
he does here based on those roots of
Ross's mustache clock I'm putting this
in the 90s Ross isn't hungry here you
can see a truck behind him that's
Hungarian for Varga and company Varga
being a surname and underneath that land
in sea shipping music of this trailers
fantastic there's this heavy electric
string distortion sound those music is
being composed by Henry Jackman who
scored Winter Soldier in Civil War and
Tomatoes composition reminds me of Hans
Zimmer's mombasa theme from inception
which also accompanied a high paced
espionage foot chase
[Music]
typical of spy movies natasha has
several fake IDs and passports there's
one for California
looks like the name ie Herbert in the
signature there and another for British
Columbia with the name is Samantha Rene
berezin there's also a stack of
passports the top of which is the United
Kingdom passports there's also some
paperwork with Hebrew lettering on it
perhaps citizenship paperwork for Israel
another country known as a hotspot for
international intrigue and espionage
Natasha heads into an apartment footage
that Comic Con attendees we're lucky
enough to see last summer she leads us
to the next clip I know you know around
here so we're gonna talk like grown-ups
is it we are
Natasha paces Yelena biloba played here
by Florence Pugh in the comic see Lena
Bulova is a rival spy from the KGB
red-room who hunts down Natasha Romanov
to try to steal the Black Widow title
from her this movie The Black Widow
title is shared among several spies from
the Red Room including these two along
with Rachel vices character Melina
maybe Melina Busta Cove okay I made it
but we will know her last name yet they
fight with perfectly mirrored moves like
they try to steal each other's guns but
they just swap guns showing they've been
trained in the same exact way or maybe
this is all just Natasha losing her mind
like a cat fighting a mirror in this
apartment there's a poster for a German
opera along with a drum kit from Guitar
Hero World Tour I remember those days
that game came out in 2008 which could
help us narrow down the timeline here
like the earlier time period could be as
late as 2008 which would be right before
Tony Stark became Iron Man and a couple
years before Natasha would work with
fury to recruit Tony to the Avengers
initiative and Iron Man 2 or you know
this could just be set in a post-civil
war period I'm feeling it just likes the
old games on Elena's wall is more spice
[ __ ] there's a map of us can you tell
from the Danube River stretching up
vertically through the city
there's red markers and other photos
covering it I have some more thoughts
and what this could be later in this
video it's actually defends herself from
Yelena's knife with what's that a
stapler and to me this fight definitely
parallels the opening brawl between the
bride and Vernita green and Kill Bill
Yelena uses a dishrag to wrap around
Nats arm flipster and smashes her leg
through the window glass which
definitely should give someone a
laceration if that happens to you but
it's a movie so she walks it off let's
move on it's good to see you
what brings you home reg Natasha
refers to Galina as cysts referring to
their sisterly bond from their shared
experience in the Red Room Yelena asks
what brings her home suggesting that
will see Budapest maybe in both time
periods of this movie natasha has made a
number of visits back to the motherland
in the former Soviet bloc over the years
including a trip between Winter Soldier
and civil war to track down her parents
revealed in the deleted scenes Civil War
after everything happened shield during
my little hiatus I went back to Russia
and tried to find my parents two little
gravestones by a chain-link fence I
pulled some weeds and left some flowers
then they peel out on a motorcycle
through the streets of Budapest and we
move on we have to go back to where it
all started
okay here at Natasha stands among what
looks like a crash site wasn't some bag
as what looks like Ross's SV Brigade
rolls in and then back to Natasha I'm
Yelena
fleeing someone and using this teetering
smokestack it's kind of a pole vault
there's a third woman with them could be
Melina kind of hard to tell from this
distance Yelena notice has a backpack
there which looks like the one attaches
holding and that crash shot earlier
perhaps containing something for some
significance the most cryptic shot of
this trailer comes right here in this
dark room with window shutters blacking
out the sunlight there are some
intimated odds and ends on the table
including projector slides and a
chessboard the ultimate game of Russia
making me think this could be like a red
room command center in the past there's
a young agent case seen a man to me this
looks like that shot of Melina there's a
later shot of Rachel bison which she
looks a bit younger and man
maybe I'm reaching here he does have
similar slicked back hair as a young a
Thunderbolt Ross above them are these 16
screens that appear to show city
overhead maps and red dots spread
throughout now these glowing dots match
the glowing red bands on the arms of the
female assets we see later in the
trailer there are about 16 or 17 women
in that room maybe these are all Black
Widow agents deployed throughout
European cities Matt could connect what
Yelena was tracking on the map in her
room now I'll admit it's a bit odd that
Ross could be at all connected to this
KGB routed operation could we actually
just be seeing the origin of the MCU
Thunderbolt or could Ross actually be a
secret Russian asset who rose through
the ranks of the American military and
diplomatic Corp no no that's kind of
becoming an episode of total conspiracy
before we move on a helicopter
approaches a snow-covered base
presumably in Siberia where Natasha
stakes a super air landing wearing this
sweet white suit which could be a nod to
her look in the 2010 black widow deadly
origin comic series let's move on lucky
us
[Music]
it's gonna be a hell of a reunion
okay here's that shot from the other
Black Widow agents I mentioned before
could be seen in both version of the Red
Room training here and then there's the
bill into this film taskmaster
taskmaster was originally a villain from
the Avengers comics in the 80s a guy
named Tony masters who has the ability
to use muscle memory photographic
reflexes to perfectly mimic his enemy's
attacks back at them is a cape in a hood
the cold skull mask but we've also seen
mirror two tasks between yelena and
natasha suggesting that taskmaster could
actually be a mystery rogue agent from
the Red Room a lady perhaps even Molina
so you know it's Rachel Weisz if you got
an Oscar you don't sign on to a Marvel
movie just to play the brunette one and
since Hawkeye is rumored to be in this
movie the bow and arrow could indicate
that's Clint Barton under the mask a
taskmaster is a completely different
character this person could have just
picked up a variety of skill sets from
other fighters maybe the bow and arrow
from Clint and the shield that we later
see them with from fighting Red Guard II
in the past or Captain America and
speaking of red Guardian busting out of
that Siberian facility is this fella
someone I'm definitely gonna aim to
cosplay as Alexey chose to call aka red
Guardian a Soviet equivalent of Captain
America played by David Harbor red
Guardian typically doesn't have advanced
strength in the comics but here he
appears to punch down this reinforced
door I guess I'll admit it's a bit
ironic that David Harper was known as a
character who seemed to get locked away
in Russia at the end of strangers things
season 3 but I'll explore that possible
bonkers connection in another video
David Harvard is having a lot of fun in
this role he's flexing he's showing off
his Russian Prison tattoos which include
these towers of st. Basil's Cathedral on
his chest and a spiderweb on his elbow
perhaps indicating a connection to the
Black Widow program we see him in his
full glory in the next clip family
big together again you got effect
okay Alexi puts on his classic red
guardian suit which is clearly modeled
on the early version of cap suit with
the straps and the pouch is family sits
down for a dinner of vodka and there's a
super interesting detail notice Yelena's
vest this is the same exact best that
Natasha shows up wearing and Scotland an
infinity war and that folks she also
strangely changed her hair from a
classic red to short blonde I think it's
possible that this was all done to
embody the identity of her counterparts
Yelena to help disguise herself while on
the run maybe even Natasha took it on
after murdering Yelena and that is some
of the red in her ledger that she's been
trying to clear but let me know what you
think this best connection is all about
in the comments below but let's move on
to the final section
[Music]
okay Alexi fights taskmaster in this
facility if their feet is that's broken
shield as a tea on it for taskmaster
that's broken suggesting taskmaster just
chucked it I read Guardian read Guardian
smashed it into the ground
this room behind them features a number
of smaller rooms with pink lighting taps
keys are the housing cells for each of
the black widow agents the Siberia
facility collapses in an implosion maybe
an avalanche milena fires a grenade
launcher and Natasha closes out the
trailer with this insane dive through
the exploding debris and machine-gun
fire it's nuts I love it
may cannot come soon enough what are you
most looking forward to about the Black
Widow movie tie my down below with your
thoughts follow me on instagram and
twitter at a vas followed new rock stars
and socials and subscribed into rock
stars here on YouTube thanks for joining
me bye
[Music]